Nipsey Hussle z' long time love breaks
her silence about the rapper's tragic
death saying she's quote completely lost
without him Lauren London took to
Instagram on Tuesday to share eight
intimate pics of her boyfriend of five
years alongside a touching tribute quote
I am completely lost I've lost my best
friend my sanctuary my protector my soul
I'm lost without you we are lost without
you babe
I have no words Nipsey was gunned down
Sunday in Los Angeles and the LAPD has
confirmed the suspect Eric Holder was
taken into custody Tuesday without bail
Nipsey was killed outside his shop
marathon clothing in LA Hyde Park
neighborhood it's the same store where
he met 34 year old Lauren but a
first-time and personal crush on Slauson
in my store yes but what did I think
what did you say you thought or what did
know what do you think I think nipsey
and Lauren started dating in 2013 and
were rumored to be married just months
before the rapper's death one of the
tributes Knapp shows the rapper smiling
as he holds their two-year-old son cross
in the air along with candid family
photos their family also includes
Laurens nine-year-old son Cameron and
his seven year old daughter
Imani from previous relationships just
days ago nipsey proved just how well he
knew his leading lady playing the GQ
couple's quiz what's my favorite thing
to order at Starbucks since you've been
with me you copy my order okay no all of
us cinnamon Dolce I'm good I got Albany
right describe me in 3-way
this is turning to Lauren praise so
charismatic for sure I'll say like
vulnerable emotional emotional okay
that's that's honest you actress is
nothing wrong with Lauren and nipsey
frequently worked together at home and
in the community the actress was
featured in several of his music videos
including hustle and motivates and more
the couple stepped out in style for this
year's Grammys to celebrate nipsey's
nomination for his album victory lap
Nipsey Hussle creator one of the best
records the last 12 months hands down
and it's being recognized by the Grammys
Congrats man
thank you my brother thank you dude is
such a deep album and you know to know
that you're an event like this covers so
much you know somebody genres so many
different types of measely but what you
said was your truth how does it feel for
you I'm inspired obviously you don't
want to get back and make some new music
hummert I know how much we put into the
album so you know to be recognized it
mean a lot you know for my team also
everybody I worked on it
we just excited and you don't have to be
and the grammy-nominated rapper had big
plans for 2019
me music 2019 what's the update yeah so
Friday
I'm the fit tank my new single dropping
its contracts in the middle amazing
feature hit boy right here it's so we
looking forward today in the project to
follow yes so definitely this year we
come Woodie after news spread of
nipsey's untimely death hundreds of
messages of support and love poured in
for Lauren on social media Nipsey sister
Samantha Smith also posted an emotional
message for her sibling on Instagram
writing you are my heart you are my
strength my wisdom I join my balance
you are my superhero invincible to me
she went on vowing to take care of his
family now that he's gone I got Lauren I
got Imani I got cross I got mommy and
granny and pop you gave me so many tools
you gave me so much insight we will talk
every second of every day and I am here
to carry out your vision the rapper was
also set to release the doctors
semi-documentary a project Nick Cannon
has now vowed to complete on nipsey's
behalf prayers for Lauren their kids and
all of those who loved nipsey we will
keep you updated as we get more details
so be sure to subscribe to ET until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens
[Music]